hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 29 of networks a
programming and today we're gonna talk
about kicking people okay so we've got
this awesome server of course which
handles all of our clients but we have
no way of kicking people again that's
sometimes a problem we can get someone
who logs in who's just being a complete
idiot and ruining everything and we just
want him gone okay we want him to move
out permanently well permanently it's
called batting's something different but
we want we want to get rid of him okay
we want to kick him right or her so um
because of this we don't really have a
system of doing this and we should okay
so this is what this what this episode's
gonna be about okay learning how to kick
people okay so um obviously it's gonna
be a console command right that's good
good it's gonna be a command that we
give this server and in the server top
Java class or rather in the server Java
file gets a class called server we have
a method called run okay and in this run
method we have a bunch of commands that
we've written for ourselves and buy a
bunch I really mean to right now we've
got raw and we've got clients okay but
what we want to have is one more command
okay well actually we'll probably have
more than one more eventually but we
want to have a command that is say that
is essentially called kick okay so we'll
make another else--if because that's how
we make commands else if text dot equals
kick okay and this is that it's actually
the difference right the the syntax we
want to use for the kick command is
gonna be something like this right so
slash we want to say slash kick and then
maybe the username so yong-ok
or slash kick and maybe the ID okay
since we have Island since every client
has an ID so we might want to do
something like that okay we might want
to have those two options and obviously
we have kick and then kind of a
parameter okay so to set that up we
obviously would get rid of this flash
when we um we do right over here when
when we do this text equals textile
substring one we get rid of the slash
but more importantly over here in our in
in kick riot we can't do equals because
it won't be equals okay it'll be equals
if we put just the word kick but we also
want to specify a name so we have to
change this equals to a starts with okay
sorry if text starts with
kick is clearly gonna be a kick command
now let's handle that okay first thing
we want to do is get the name okay or at
least figure out if it's a name or an ID
right we don't want to have to put like
a flag at the end being like all right
kick 8 - 2 - that identifier and then we
want to be like oh by the way that's not
idea so let's specify that we want to do
that right we kind of know that if it's
a if it's a if it's a number it's not
gonna be a user okay obviously if it's a
mixture of letters and numbers it could
be a username but if it's just numbers
it is not a username it's an ID okay so
we've got up we have to kind of let well
we'll just let the we'll just let the
server kind of figure it out okay
if it's a string of numbers then it's
gonna be an ID
otherwise it's a name okay so let's make
a string we'll call it name for now and
we'll just set it equal to essentially
just the second half of this kick
command since we type in / ke on we want
to kind of just extract the name out of
that okay and the way that we can do
that of course is simply use our text
here dot split and then the the rejects
here will just be a space okay and the
reason is more of it wrong you know okay
it's an array that'll be one now the
reason it's gonna be that is because of
course the difference I guess the thing
that divides yarn here is as you can say
a space okay so if we get rid of that
space we're left with two strings here
we're left with this slash all this kick
because the slash has been removed
earlier and yon now this is IDs this is
this is index 0 in the array and this is
the next one and we won of course 1
because that's the name thus we have one
in here okay I hope you guys understand
this we've done a lot of this splitting
stuff but um if you guys might not get
it yet so there's a better explanation
hopefully all right now we want to kind
of figure out is it a number or is it
not a number okay and we can do that
pretty easily first of all let's just
grab a boolean called num will set it
equal to false again the easiest way
probably to find out with whether
something is a number or not is well
actually the easiest way to find out
whether a string is a knob is a number
or not is just try and convert it to a
number and see if that works okay so
try and set that's actually okay so
first of all we should make an integer
called ID I'll set that equal to
negative one which kind of means it's
not in use and then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna try an integer dot pass
int our text here again we'll actually
try and set that equal to ID okay so if
it works right
we'll set number equal to true right
otherwise if we catch an exception here
in the exception that we're going to be
catching of course is the number format
exception and I'll explain what all this
is in a minute then we will we'll set a
number equal to false means it's not a
number okay so the essentially what
happens here is we try and convert this
text variable this text old text own
name
sorry my bad we try and convert this
name string into a number okay if it's
not a number so for something like a on
and we can't convert yon into a number
clearly it's it's just it's a word if we
try and convert that that name into a
number and it turns out that the name is
actually text then then it'll throw out
that then this integers are passing it
will throw an exception which was called
a number format exception because the
thing that we're trying to convert is
actually not a number and of course the
way that we can simply gonna handle that
is what I'm just going to set normal to
false okay
simple as that what we could do to
probably make this a bit easier is just
to get rid of this number equals true
line and then just make it true by
default okay again it's up to you just a
minor change but we will keep it as that
for now sorry if it is a number again
I'll just I'll just change this to a
number just for readability here so if
not if the if a little R if a little
name here is actually a number means it
and it's an ID right so first of all
we'll find out well someone's just
entered an ID we want to kick someone
with a particular ID does that ID
actually exist right we might have we
might have entered the incorrect ID or
maybe the user has just been acted blah
blah we want to check to see if the ID
exists so we'll make a boolean here
called exists
okay and we'll set that equal to false
for now sorry for each of the clients
that we have in this entire thing here
so if client store size for each of our
connected clients to the server we want
to first of all
whoops what about done here is less than
closer sighs we want to basically a
check to see if if clients don't get I
dot get ID is equal to our ID here okay
because of course if it's a number it
won't be negative one anymore because we
set it equal to this if it is equal to
ID right then obviously exist is going
to be true and then we can break because
we don't need to keep checking all the
other clients if we found one that does
exist okay and then all we have to do
here is first of all first of all we
should say if I guess if exists right if
if our client does exist because our
boolean here it gets set to true if if
we found a client with it with the
specified ad let's just kick him right
so disconnect ID right and true so in
other words we've caused the
disconnection it's organic it's not a
it's not like a time outer or a network
error it's it's it's it's fine however
else right if we did not find any client
there then which probably just tell the
the server that you know the client with
you know this ID doesn't exist right
check ID number something like that just
something helpful to let us know that
okay it's failed the user wasn't
disconnected okay else right so in other
words if if the name is on a number
right then it's obviously the name of
the client right it's the username so
again we have to do kind of the same
thing for in I equals zero I is less
than clients dot size I plus plus then
we will set server client C equal to
clients don't get I all right just to
make this a bit easier because there's
gonna be a lot of part comparisons here
well what we'll do here is we'll just
simply say that if if name right dot
equals C dot name okay
then basically what's happened here is
we've gone ahead and said that if the
name that we specified matches a user
name of a
have a client then we found our username
right so let's disconnect with and the
ID here by the way it's gonna be our
seed get ID of course because it's the
current server client that we're
checking in this sign is for loop and
the service again will be true right
just like last time now we also need a
break because we don't want to keep
checking all the other clients if if we
already found the one to disconnect now
one thing that's actually going to stop
us from working okay this name dot
equals CNM will obviously check check
they'll just compare the two the two
strings and it will see if they're equal
however if we if we just remind
ourselves of how we even get this name
you'll see over here that um we get it
by connection right we're making new
server client and this first parameter
is the name now we string string here is
straight from the packet as you can see
packet data we all know that our Pat the
size of our packets at 1024 bytes and
you can see here what we do is whoops we
don't have an end character and we
simply trim it to three because the
first three characters are this
flashlight sorry / say slash and then we
just go ahead and say string that length
okay and what that does is it creates a
username that has a lot of spaces at the
end so what we should do is actually add
an end character and trim it properly
okay just like we do here so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say a string name
equals our string dot split okay and the
rejects here is gonna be /c / or / a /
okay and we'll set this equal to one of
course
whoops make sure you end that so now no
buzz is exactly the same as this D
there's this big kind of disconnection
thing what we have is / D yeah it's
exactly the same as that except for the
slash C okay now I'm and over here of
course will change this string to a
substring thing to a name to just to
this name string that we've just created
okay brilliant
now we also print out I think yet this
let's get rid of that that's just the
name of the client we want to print that
rather we'll print something like this
user connected right so
well God will go ahead and say maybe
something along the lines of name plus
and then we'll just put the iodine
brackets here so like this connected
right and then this message might be
relayed to all the clients if we so
choose but essentially that just lets us
know that we connected right okay
brilliant so what we can do now is
pretty much this is out now obviously
we've gone ahead and said okay let's
let's split this string based on these n
character there's actually a pipe at the
end as well for some reason but we want
to we want to split it on this slash a
slash but of course we never send this
slash a slash so we have to go back to
our client window here I believe and
let's find where we connect so I think
it's over here yeah connection will get
bite so here we go a string connection
we want to just basically append a slash
a slash onto the end of that and we
should be good to go
okay that's very important because we
have a massive trail of white spaces at
the end of that it doesn't just send you
no yarn like that it sends yarn with
blah blah like this that's why we want
to trim all that and make it work
properly okay the Java string trim
command by the way won't work for this
that's why it's important but we use
these slash eight characters
brilliant okay whoops I just okay there
we go sweet so let's test this out now
right we'll launch our seven man and
I'll bring it up here so you guys can
see and and we'll launch the will go to
login and we'll launch that as well
yeah I'm localhost a-19 to login all
right
so will will can see here it says that
we connected there's our ID - what 206
that's brilliant right we can also go
slash clients that's from the previous
episode to see our ID yet again okay and
now we can probably kick ourselves right
so first of all let's go ahead and try
and say something hey okay that did not
work okay that did oh by the way there's
a bit of an there's a bit of a bug that
you guys might have discovered if we
type something and then just wait for a
while it disappears okay and we'll
fix that in just a minute it's actually
a very easy fix I forgot to mention that
but the point is we are you can see it
kind of clears it sometimes the reason
it clears it is because we send a packet
and we clear everything I'll explain it
in a minute but um you can see that
we're talking with the server here so if
I go ahead and go slash kick and then
the let's just try the ID first there
206 type that in hit enter you can see
client yarn disconnected and if we try
and say something you can see that the
server of course will still be getting
the packets there's no reason for seven
all together packets and the reason is
you know there's nothing to actually
ensure the following connection but the
server just discards those packets all
right we print them over here but the
server just doesn't not does nothing
with them okay we could um you can't
really reject these packets right you
any anything that Connect comes to you
you will kind of process but we can
discard the ones we don't need okay and
that's what we've done here of course so
um you can see we can't talk anyone
we're not getting any feedback now
before we before we test the the other
one and you can see that we still try
and send a disconnection packet and we
have to handle that as well because the
clients already been disconnected but
let's go ahead and fix that bug first so
if we go into this is very important as
well as make sure you do this to
yourselves as well if you go into client
window you'll see a you'll see this send
a little method here right and so what
what we're basically doing is we're
using this send method to send messages
right so every time we hit enter or we
call we click the send button in our
client window we send a message
now however all right on the other side
we that's not the only thing we use it
for okay you can see over here that you
found message starts with I that's
obviously a server verification packet
we we go ahead and send a reply and we
use this send method so every time we
reply to the service are you there still
client message we still um with it we
actually end up clearing this this text
message box right so that text field
where you can type your your message
essentially is getting cleared every
time we use this send method okay we
only want to clear it when we send a
message not when our client replies to
the server's
message so to fix that let's cut this
and just put it into here okay
so I've just put this text message from
being outside this if text to being
inside okay and the reason is this text
of course lets us know that what we're
sending is a client message that in
other words the users typed out a
message in the chat program and hit
enter or click or hit the send button
right so in other words you can see that
we append am here to basically just to
let the server know it's a message and
you know all that good stuff and also we
clear the box only if that happens okay
very important stuff and then you'll see
here that if we launch our server again
and we'll test out the name thing in a
minute but whoops if we if we open this
up now if we um if we launch our server
here and we launch our login you can see
that our first of all let's see if the
bug resolved itself and I'm pretty sure
it would have if we type something in
it's up in hey you can see it's not
disappearing okay and it'll stay like
that forever until we hit the send
button or we actually hit enter okay you
can see that that works fun
all right great now let's just connect
our little client here okay
so we'll type in slash kick yawn alright
and you can see that it's worked client
disconnected and we're no longer able to
actually receive messages okay so just
like that that's gonna wrap up this
episode and I wish our programming
episode 29 next episode I think what
we're going to do is is actually you
know what before we wrap it up I
actually forgot about this if you hit
the close button you can see we get an
exception so in a little - server
frickin crashes and you can say that of
course eclipses just told us here that
we get a null pointer exception because
um because the client doesn't exist okay
so what we should do here because it's
trying to access see here and you can
see if I hover my mouse over a lot of
people ask me how I might make a quick
series on how to diagnose errors and
stuff like that because it's really
important I think I might just do that
in the learning Java series that I want
to do soon but um if we hover our name
over C right it'll actually tell us that
C equals null okay so in other words
this server client is equal to null and
the reason is equal to null is because
it couldn't find it in here
okay a quick way to check this oh well
actually well not really to check this
but a quick way to prevent this is to
say let's just fine let's just see if we
can find the client with that ID okay
now we've already got this awesome
little full loop in here okay and it
checks an ID here so if I guess what we
kind of need to set up is a again a
boolean here that says exists all right
bullying exists equals false okay
and then whenever this whenever we do
actually whoops let's just terminate our
application first whenever we do
actually remove the client yeah so in
other words when we find the client with
the ID and we do remove the client as
you can see over here let's just go
ahead and say exists equals true okay
and which property changes to existed
okay because we just removed them but um
to true okay and over here we can say a
simple if if does not exist as of you
know if it doesn't exist then let's just
return okay let's not do the rest of the
code in this in this method because we
don't want to be we don't want to be
printing stuff out from now on causing
our pointer exceptions okay so that's as
simple as that is okay let's just test
it out quickly again if we open up our
server main open up our login oops
open up our log and of course you're on
localhost oops I want on to login all
right we'll type in slash kick slash
kick Yan class is connected let's close
the close button here and as you can see
we get nowhere as well so ever our
server is still running perfectly we can
check how many clients are online casino
one is and we can do stuff like that
okay
that's gonna pretty much end this
episode of never watch a program I hope
you guys did enjoy it a slash quit would
be nice we might do that the episode are
often x1 or whatever but next episode I
do want to focus on one pretty important
thing that you guys want to want to see
in basically that is having a um in our
log anything here we want to be able to
maybe have like a menu on the top and we
want to be able to click a button and
then see who's online so maybe like a
dialog box pops up or we can type in
you command I don't know you guys decide
okay you guys decide what kind of
graphical user interface you want for
this okay whether that be command
whether we can type in something like
slash online again and it'll basically
check to see who's online okay and it'll
print out just just locally into our
console here who's online or maybe you
want like a button here that we press in
it and it just it comes up with another
window that has a list of who's online
okay
maybe something like that anyway let me
know or like a permanent like toggle a
lot like maybe like a tab that you can
toggle and it'll it'll say there forever
attached to this window it'll just tell
you who's on line essentially until you
close it or whatever I don't know you
guys decide but um that's gonna wrap off
this episode of net without programming
let's try and disconnect you on again
what via the ID this time seven and 70
works okay we're out nice little voice
crack for you guys and I'll see you guys
next time be sure to LIKE the video if
you did later guys